Victoria gray isn't used to the
Limelight a mum from Mississippi she's
now the star attraction at the human
genome editing Summit in London here to
describe the treatment that's changed
her life
I think it is a great thing who doesn't
want a good quality of life where you
don't have to suffer because my disease
I didn't choose I was just born
having to endure pain and hospital stays
it was a life that I felt wasn't worth
living
Victoria has been cured of debilitating
sickle cell disease by an experimental
Gene editing treatment her story
represents a major Advance with
implications for Millions born with the
rare blood disease each year inherited
diseases like Sickle Cell cystic
fibrosis and Huntington's begin as
variations in genes the codes in human
DNA that tell the body how to make cells
new tools like the so-called crispr
system confined cut and replace faulty
parts of genes to deliver a corrected
genetic code
senior researchers like fyodor urnov
foresee a world in which crispr is able
to provide a rapid cure for the genetic
mutations it encounters the next Horizon
the next big breakthrough for us as a
community is to take that amazing
technology and make it available
manufactured at such scale for the tens
of millions around the world who have a
mutation that needs to be crispered
today
it is a goal that raises important
ethical concerns one of the greatest
concerns is that we're really moving
into what many people would call
potentially not yet but soon a soft
eugenics in which it's not just what do
you want to have a baby it's what kind
of baby do you want to have and you know
the potential for enhancement is there
to be clear no one at this Summit is
talking about eugenics in fact when a
Chinese scientist announced in this very
Forum five years ago that he'd altered
the genetic makeup of embryos in a lab
and then brought them to term his
announcement was met with shock and
outrage
I felt like I had nothing to lose I was
at the end
but very precise editing of genetic code
to treat and cure rare diseases is
making its way from the experimental to
the Practical albeit currently at
enormous cost the next great challenge
is to make it accessible and affordable
Jonah Al Jazeera London